[Musik]
Stillstand bei der Deutschen Bahn nach
einem Sabotageakt am vergangenen Samstag
ruht der Schienenverkehr in ganz
Norddeutschland
zigtausende Fahrgäste wie hier im
Hamburger Bahnhof gestrandet
also wir warten schon sehr lange
die Stimmung ist natürlich nicht gut
weil wir müssen nach Berlin und vom
Berlin aus müssen wir in die Flughafen
der verfassen unser Flug doch am
Wochenende ging es um weit mehr als um
eine ganz normale Verspätung unbekannter
hatten das zentrale Kommunikationssystem
der Bahn unterbrochen in Berlin und im
nordrhein-westfälischen Herne finden die
Ermittler durchgesägte Kabel die Täter
so die Bahn besaßen Insiderkenntnisse
wussten wie man mit geringem Aufwand
großen Schaden anrichtet
sicherheitsexperten warnen vor möglichen
weiteren Angriffen
es zeigt wie verwundbar wir als
Gesellschaft sind mit unserer kritischen
Infrastruktur das fängt beim
Transportwesen Bahn zum Beispiel an
könnte aber genauso auch
Kommunikationsnetze sein könnte auch
Energiewirtschaft sein Kraftwerke oder
ähnliches und dann setzt sich das sofort
natürlich auch in den maritimen Bereich
wie wir es zum Beispiel mit dem
Pipelines gesehen haben
Anschlag auf die Pipelines nordstream 1
und nordstream 2 die erste Explosion am
26 September das schwedische Institut
für seismografie meldet heftige
Erschütterungen vor der
dänisch-schwedischen Küste die
schwedische Küstenwache macht sich auf
den Weg entdeckt schließlich vier Lex
die Staatsanwaltschaft geht von Sabotage
aus
wer genau die Täter waren steht für die
Ermittler noch nicht fest aber viele
Schweden sind sich da sicher
ich denke es sind die Russen
er zeigt uns ich kann mir alles erlauben
wenn ihr nicht nach meiner Pfeife tanzt
das Beste was wir machen können ist die
Ukraine zu unterstützen und so schnell
wie möglich Putin in die Schranken zu
weisen
der schwedische Sicherheitsexperte
Niklas Rosbach sagt Putin habe zumindest
ein Motiv
so etwas anzurichten ergibt Sinn für die
Russen
erstens sind die Pipelines nicht in
Betrieb wohl auch in Zukunft nicht mehr
denn die Europäer werden weniger
russisches Gas importieren auch bei
verbesserten Beziehungen
eine zerstörte Pipeline ist das
Propaganda-Instrument für die Russen und
ihre Unterstützer womöglich wertvoller
als eine funktionierende denn damit
können Sie Desinformationen verbreiten
inzwischen hat auch die deutsche
Bundesanwaltschaft Ermittlungen
aufgenommen der Anschlag auf Nord Stream
sei geeignet die äußere und innere
Sicherheit Deutschlands zu
beeinträchtigen
auch der deutsche Sicherheitspolitiker
Roderich Kiesewetter vermutet Russland
hinter den Anschlägen
zum einen ist das eine Frage der
Verunsicherung bewusst Hybride
Kriegsführung durch Terror durch
Zerstörung der Energieinfrastruktur mit
dazu beizutragen dass unser ganzes
Gesellschaftssystem die stabilisiert
wird und das zweite ist natürlich zu
zeigen wie verwundbar unsere
Gesellschaften sind und wir sind
verwundbar
dagegen behauptet das russische
Staatsfernsehen ein Tag nach dem
Anschlag auf die Ostsee-Pipeline die USA
seien verantwortlich als vermeintlicher
Beleg dient eine Aussage von
US-Präsident Joe Biden kurz vor
Kriegsausbruch im Februar
wenn Russland einmarschiert das bedeutet
dass Panzer und Soldaten die Grenze zu
Ukraine erneut überschreiten dann wird
es kein nordstream 2 mehr geben wir
werden dem ein Ende bereiten
Präsident Putin beschuldigt den Westen
ohne Belege Angus sagst die Sanktionen
gegen Russland reichen den Angelsachsen
nicht mehr jetzt greifen sie zur
Sabotage das ist Fakt sie haben die
Explosionen an den internationalen
Gaspipelines auf dem Boden der Ostsee
organisiert und faktisch damit begonnen
die europäische Energieinfrastruktur zu
zerstören ich glaube es macht überhaupt
keinen Sinn zu unterstellen dass das
beispielsweise die Briten oder auch die
polenbalten oder die Amerikaner waren
weil keines dieser Länder ein Interesse
daran hat den europäischen und auch
transatlantischen Zusammenhalt zu
zerstören
Rotterdam Europas größter Hafen hier
lagert Flüssiggas die sogenannten LNG
Gasspeicher haben eine Kapazität von 12
Billionen Kubikmeter sie versorgen nicht
nur die Niederlande sondern ganz
Nordwesteuropa mit der Abkehr vom
russischen Gas wird der Hafen noch
wichtiger bei der europäischen
Energieversorgung ohne Rotterdam stünde
Deutschland schlecht da
Sicherheitsexperten wie gänserie Grein
hier drängen auf einen besseren Schutz
der Infrastruktur
ich glaube dass wir jetzt in einer
Situation sind wo wir vorsichtig sein
müssen wir sehen nordstream 2 und alles
was in Russland und der Ukraine passiert
und eh man sich versieht ist man in
einer Situation wo auch wir ein
mögliches Ziel werden
das Hafengebiet erstreckt sich über eine
Fläche von mehr als 12.000 Hektar rund
70.000 Menschen arbeiten hier
angesichts der neuen Gefahren reichen
herkömmliche Sicherheitsmaßnahmen nicht
mehr aussagt ranier
ich glaube man braucht eine echte
Sicherheitsstrategie eine Security nicht
nur eine Pforte mit einem Bewacher und
ein paar Kameras sondern eine strenge
Prüfung was sind die schwärzesten
Szenarien und die größten Risiken
denn ein gezielter Sabotageakt kann
gerade hier schwerwiegende Folgen haben
unsere Häfen sind das wirtschaftliche
Herz das Zentrum der belgischen und
niederländischen Wirtschaft selbst von
Europa
was passieren kann zeigte sich vor zwei
Jahren ein Unfall im norwegischen
Hammerfest aus einem lng-terminal war
Gas ausgetreten der ganze Hafen in
Flammen die Instandsetzung der Anlagen
dauerte anderthalb Jahre
ein neues lng-terminal wird gerade in
Wilhelmshaven an der deutschen
Nordseeküste gebaut eines von vier nach
rund zehn Monaten Bauzeit soll die
Anlage im Dezember in Betrieb gehen und
Deutschland damit unabhängiger machen
von russischem Gas nach den Anschlägen
in der Ostsee gilt das neue Terminal als
Anschlagsziel deshalb nun rund um die
Uhr Überwachung durch die Polizei das
Gelände wird abgeschirmt Kameras und
Bewegungsmelder kein Unbekannter soll
hier eindringen reicht das wir legen
natürlich als betreiberkritischer
Infrastruktur höchstenswert darauf
unsere Anlagen unsere Kraftwerke
flüssiggast Terminals und Gasspeicher
und ähnliches zu schützen und deshalb
werden da detaillierte Konzepte
Sicherheitskonzepte ausgearbeitet
kontinuierlich ausgearbeitet und
permanent auch verbessert um die
Infrastruktur eben zu schützen vor
dieser Art von Sabotage
wer hinter der Sabotage auf die Bahn
steckt ist weiterhin ungeklärt
inzwischen ermitteln die
Landeskriminalämter Berlin und
Nordrhein-Westfalen sowie der
Staatsschutz
den deutschen wird klar die kritische
Infrastruktur im Land ist nicht sicher